all right
i might need help getting these on great
let's wait save it save it save it save
it save it save it save it save it are
we recording
yeah we are
there we go oh thank you megan
uh you guys are good definitely going to
see me wince
uh a number of times over the course of
this uh
podcast i will be
wincing um because the pain medication
has not quite kicked in yet now what are
we on
uh well
uh
just uh tylenol and percocet okay
yeah i which i had to fight really hard
to get because the opioid crisis is is
has basically
made things like
impossible to get something and it's
like
you know i have a broken bone i i think
like i should be able like the
orthopedist that i went to um
who by the way said i was gonna heal in
three weeks and i didn't need surgery so
that's that's good that's good news
couldn't prescribe me um a narcotic
and i'm like
you're a surgeon like you i have a
broken bone like you can't give me some
because they gave me percocet at the uh
er
and uh
and it worked
like it works it does it does what it's
supposed to do it like makes you not
feel the pain you know what i mean and
then when i ran out of that and just was
using tylenol i was like this is
horrible yeah i'm in horrendous pain
they say though if you combine the
tylenol with an ibuprofen
that's that it's as effective as a
narcotic but and you don't have the sort
of like um yeah either speedy or like uh
super fatigue you don't get the fun part
you don't get the fun part but but it's
fun for you if it's fun for something
yeah some people don't like it yes
i also find it hard to believe this is
going to heal in three weeks i
snapped my collarbone in half uh i don't
really understand but uh that's what he
said and
now can you tell us the comedic version
of what happened or is it just gonna be
like a drag yeah like did you yeah did
you do a funny kind of like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was a garbage can and
was there like a tell us the story
it was the uh it was the la okay so uh
my wife and my i took my wife and kids
and nephew and uh we all went
snowboarding in mammoth uh which
we do many many times a year every year
i've been doing this for a long time and
uh
it was on the last run of the last day
and the the crazy thing is i was i was
at the top and i was talking to my buddy
shane who lives you maybe you've met
shane have you met shane uh jill's
friend from high school who lives in
mammoth shane hennis
no so shane uh he he always comes out
and boards with us he lives in mammoth
and uh and
we were at the top and i told shannon i
was like yeah this is my last run and he
goes oh no
he's like dude never say that
never say that that's really bad luck
and i was like really and he was like
yeah like you've never heard that i'm
like no i was like i was like okay and i
made a joke i was like i was like this
is not my last run
i'm going to go on a number of runs do
you think because he said that to you
you were maybe a little extra tight or
something like i don't know but it but i
i
you know and he felt really bad too
because i think he thought maybe that he
got in my head but he was just joking
around but no it is it is an actual
superstition amongst uh sure skiers can
we set the scene a little bit more so
the because they're viewers now but
they're there are listeners who have no
idea what we're talking about what do
you mean
we haven't addressed that you've been
hurt oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm sorry
we dove right in okay so he has a giant
cast that i believe will all sign
his uh his leg is immobilized not a cast
it's a sling his leg is immobilized no
i'm setting him he's trying to do a
dramatic yeah i was just making sure i
think sorry last night sorry that's okay
okay so you didn't secret and you're in
pain okay this should be this should be
great megan yeah he's looking great but
his jokes are bad
so no uh so okay so i broke my clavicle
um i snapped my clavicle um i was going
off a jump
uh at the very almost the very beginning
of a run i was doing the park oh
yeah it's probably not something a 45
year old man should still like
what age do you stop
doing jumping
when do you stop going to parks just in
general like i mean playgrounds more
because they they call it a park but
really it's a playground for children
well no
no it's like big jumps inside i know but
what i'm saying is it would be
equivalent when you say a park you think
oh central park it's a nice like place
to but what that is is like an adventure
land of
moguls and and jumps and it's quite
dangerous for people who don't ski or
snowboard the park is the is the section
on certain runs that they have where
they have like
you know jumps and boxes they have like
features that you can do crazy [ __ ] off
of on your skis or snowboard
uh and i was going off uh a particularly
high big jump and one that i'd done many
times before and landed
beautifully
um
and i did not land beautifully this time
this time i landed right on a corner and
i caught an edge
and it whipped me to the ground at a
speed that is beyond my comprehension
because i literally remember i landed on
the corner and then i was on the ground
yeah and and i and and i
hit my head so hard
so so [ __ ] hard like if i if i didn't
have a helmet on i would 100 be dead
100 there's no doubt in my mind i'd be
dead right now if i wasn't wearing a
helmet so please everybody out there
when you're snowboarding when you're
skiing even when you're skiing i mean
it's more important when you're
snowboarding i think
because i
because like when you're skiing you you
kind of you tend to fall on your side
because your skis are going this way but
when you're on a snowboard it's so easy
to whip backwards and fall back onto
your head or forward
so that's what it was you whipped
backwards
no i actually don't know i don't i don't
understand how i landed on my shoulders
like you're on a snowboard how do you
land on your shoulder because the board
is going if you turn you i guess you
turned your body yeah i so i i'm not
quite sure what happened but i think i
landed on my shoulder first and then
you know whipped my head into the ground
broke the clavicle but weirdly the thing
that hurts more than that is the
is my back
it like jacked my back up really bad so
that's the thing that i'm that that i'm
experiencing that i'm experiencing the
most pain with is is my back
it's such a dangerous sport you're
flying down a mountain
you're flying down a mountain and
gravity
is pulling you down as fast as possible
a guy there's an actor that just got
killed yeah yeah yeah somebody's just so
sad you know yeah like a french actor
right yeah yeah i heard her die all the
time
yeah
yeah it's uh i mean
yeah but it's also i the few times that
i've gone it is very fun it's super fun
so fun you know and and uh you know if
you're a radical person yeah yeah who
wants to stay right
radical and you want to shred it you
have to shred yourself but the problem
with that like is it's i i imagine now
that like jill is taking care of both
your boys and has to like open a can of
peas for you it feels very unradical
yeah yeah she's got to rinse your kale
you can't do it it actually hurts
okay let's try not to make linen laughs
oh wow
okay about power through right
i do enjoy i do
enjoy a good laugh
[Music]
uh i took my first shower last night in
many many days that felt good
great and bad because it hurt everything
hurts it hurts
um i don't know if you guys know this
but broken bones hurt
i i don't really know it i should have
broken the bone a little hairline
but i think i broke a cup i think i've
broken a couple toes like stubbing them
you know because they wherever they've
turned like really stiff and blue and
swollen but uh but i've never really
broken a bone before rob was mentioning
um you want to bring it up yeah yeah the
i i was listening to the the most recent
podcast the gang exploits a miracle um
and
i
you are talking very specifically about
doing stunts because you you did one
where you felt we were talking about how
great the stunt was you feel like a stop
off the stool yeah and you were like you
know back when i was younger i would do
i would do those kinds of stunts and it
was like it would be fun but now i'd be
nervous that i would like break my
shoulder if you literally say like i'm
gonna like separate my shoulder so i
don't like do stupid things anymore like
that because i don't want to hurt my
shoulder
oh man can you classify skiing as stupid
yes i do think i but also fun
undeniably fun there's just a risk
involved it's like if you want to ski
you want to go to you want to ski the
park as you say you want to ride a
motorcycle there's a risks involved
yeah so i know you know what i mean like
that's how i instead makes you if
there's something about being just on
the edge of breaking something or really
hurting yourself that like makes you
feel alive
yeah yeah you know you know right yeah
you've gotten pretty you've shredded
some serious gnar i have i have but i've
sl i've slowed down what was the last
time you don't know
last year
if my kids were super into it i would go
i we didn't learn i didn't learn how to
skate the first time i went skiing i was
in i was in my 30s i think and the same
for you right oh when when we did the
episode was that the first time you'd
ever skated when we did it
i don't know why you're a bachelor party
nobody was i was snowboarding then but i
learned how to snowboard in my like i
was 30 or 31. same yeah yeah obviously
we learned we learned at the same time
the same time yeah yeah because uh we
were going out with zach knighton he
yeah he was like taking us to big bear
and stuff like that and i'd been skiing
my whole life but i i always wanted to
try it was super fun i just see more and
more people getting very seriously hurt
and i'm like i enjoy it but not enough
really for that yeah yeah i went like
twice as a kid to a place called yagu
ski valley in rhode island so it was
more like a hill than a mountain there
was like one chair but you were down at
the bottom of the chair in 10 minutes
you know uh
and then i didn't go again until your
bachelor party
uh so i was in my 30s or whatever and
the very first run i went with you guys
and
you guys all just went flying down the
hill and i was like where the [ __ ] am i
i'm like oh i'm on like a triple black
diamond
and i was like i can see like a cliff to
my left and i'm like
how the [ __ ] am i gonna get down this
thing and i basically you know you'll be
fine you'll be fine just go just go
let's go
well i figured it was like a [ __ ]
ice skate so maybe it's like the edges
so i i like turn to the side i like do
that little jump and turn and then i'm
like just stopped yeah hold on a second
wait i don't know i'm being really good
at this this is what i was about to say
okay so we talked about this in an
earlier episode
maybe you wouldn't expect it but charlie
is possibly the best athlete of the
three of us and i think that's
definitely true
and this is just another example of that
because i remember you saying like i
haven't skied since i was like a kid and
i remember thinking like oh he's gonna
this is gonna be a little rough
and you look like somebody who skis
not like expert but like you you you
look like somebody who knew it well i
didn't do it but that was rough that was
going down that black diamond i wound up
going down on my butt and then being
like [ __ ] i gotta go back up on this
hill like the whole time just being like
trying to survive you know not really
like joyride just be like just let me
get to the bottom without a broken
collarbone on that first run when we did
the episode you and i went out with a
ski instructor and she's like i'll have
you
uh going down black diamonds within an
hour and she did like
but that was impressive that she was
really good and
uh that was the last time i've been on a
mountain so now i feel like if i went
again i'd have to re-learn
it would come back to you uh it's in
your body i don't want to bring some
collarbone though yeah you know yeah
yeah well it's it's it's like you said
it's like is that something that you
enjoy so much that you're willing to
possibly have a broken collarbone
because yeah the first thing i thought
was you know after i really really hurt
my ankle playing basketball in my late
20s
that pretty much was the end i mean i
still play basketball occasionally but
like i don't really play anymore because
of that
and i thought like oh no
like
am i gonna lose snowboarding it's my
favorite thing in the world to do and i
was like
but then i just kind of was like you
know what i i'll i'll heal and i'm just
going to keep doing it i'm just going to
keep doing it because it's like motor
like i like to ride a motorcycle i
learned how to ride i'm like oh this is
fun but and it's not worth it to me to
like go out and get like murdered on a
on a freeway but for so many people
they're like that the risk is worth it
to me because it's so much fun yeah it's
the whole thing gets thrown out of whack
when you have kids right like when you
have kids
it's no longer just your life right like
if i yeah it seems like it'd be very
cool to zip around on a motorcycle all
the time i think i would enjoy that but
it's i'm also like but then if i
totally no fault of my own get [ __ ]
hit by someone who's texting right and
then that's it and i'm like yeah [ __ ]
that's the thing yeah it's like my kid
has to feed me through a straw or
something for the rest of my life
because i'm paralyzed like
then that that
i don't i don't feel like i can justify
that
yes level of risk yeah maybe maybe when
they're out the door it's like hey look
you're 18 and i'm 105. i'm gonna go
ride motorcycles now or whatever but i
like that's just me i think i you know
i'm
overly cautious you're risk averse i'm
risk averse i am
you are very risk averse is he yeah i
think
not in an unhealthy way i wouldn't think
like i
i understand what you're saying but i i
wouldn't have thought of you that way
that that means
he's more measured like i i we tend to
go like all like hot i mean various
things and yeah yeah not that he doesn't
get hot but or both charlie
[Music]
this is ancient knowledge okay
um that's never gonna change like where
you are born
in relation to the stars is who you are
there's nothing you can do about it
urinaries i'm in aries and that's just
the way it's hot and we're just radical
by nature
by nature yeah no that's just how it is
oh that sounds like a cool band name we
should start radical by nature oh
it's good and bad too close to naughty
by nature i know yeah that's it yeah
yeah and nobody by nature is just a
better name but we're not naughty we're
radical
you've never been radical by reputation
[Applause]
this is the first episode of season
three
yeah so
we're picked up for one
season yeah yes they picked us up for
once one season yep
we have 15 episodes 15 episodes so we're
excited about that and we don't realize
yet how difficult that's going to be for
us
um
we have an office for the first time
mm-hmm
in marina del rey
uh couldn't be further from my house
this is actually playa del rey it's
already that's right
uh a good long commute for me oh yeah
crazy i couldn't believe it brutal crazy
you really took one for the team
it's a real pattern as i drove into this
podcast this morning it's like we've set
up a real like never has there ever been
an office in my neighborhood well no you
know you guys have never quite
the office was in playa del rey and
people outside of california might not
understand the geography but just this
this will give you a good sense where i
lived was marina del rey so yeah
which is right next to
marina del rey yeah so they were all
kind of right now it was like an hour
and a half away you might as well build
another [ __ ] planet
i didn't i don't mind to drive but um
those offices were
a dump yeah right oh but we had stages
next to them yes yes also a dump they
weren't really stages they were they
were like out they were old like
factories or something and they had out
quote unquote outfitted it but it was
also by the airport well that's what i
was gonna say i remember i remember like
those stages because that's the whole
point of of being on a stage right as
you're in a very controlled environment
where you control the sound and the look
and everything you know it's but you
could hear every single area literally
next to [ __ ] lax so every eight
minutes a new plane would go would go
over yeah which you just don't realize
you're not thinking about it when you're
not on a sound stage and everybody's
quiet how often an airplane is going
over yeah soundstage is a real generous
term for what that was it was like a
warehouse that like they just finally
stopped like using as a chop shop and
they're like you want to make a movie
here yeah go ahead yeah is that
soundproof yeah yeah
sure
what do you mean like a roof yeah we got
a roof
um it's not quite what we mean right now
yeah uh i think that was the first year
we had an assistant it was yeah adam
stein adams yeah almost cuz he would get
us coffees from starbucks every morning
and that's the first time i had like
someone like getting us a coffee right
that felt very hollywood it felt very
professional would you guys like
something in the morning yes please i
would like a coffee and then it would be
there you would you'd show up and they
would hand you a coffee and you'd be
like this is cold and we had a writing
staff we interact and get another one
let's make sure it's hot scream at them
yeah immediately that's have to go in
there
like
depending on the level of scalding you
know how hot it was you're like i'm
sorry that was perfectly hot yeah right
this is back when you could get away
with it yeah yeah but give me another
yeah um give me another one we had a
writing staff for the first time yes
we have found rob rozelle
uh scott martyr who at the time were a
writing team rose
who were yeah they were so funny and
brought so much to what the show became
wasn't the staff just martyr roselle and
hornsby or did we have one was lisa
parsons oh we had lisa park yeah i think
lisa parsons i remember lisa was
obsessed with being on um wheel of
fortune oh yeah she oh yeah i watched
everything absolutely wanted to be on
wheel of fortune right i feel like maybe
she had been part of the pitch of this
episode or i can't remember yeah i know
she was she was heavily involved in the
uh the gang solves the
north korea situation yeah is that
season three or four
three that is three i always think of it
as four but yeah you're right okay well
yeah the martyr and roselle i mean they
changed in in the best of ways um the
voice of the show in like so many
different ways which is great like i can
see their influence in this particular
episode and then it never changes what
do you see specifically in this episode
uh that would have been a martyr roselle
style joke well oddly enough they might
not even be like
as typical as like where we really got
to which was like
melting dogs in the in the in the in the
alley but even just the scene the scene
where i come in with to d with the baby
and instantly we morph into like a
married dog
that was you yeah i feel like that's
very i don't know this for i don't know
this for a fact but i that is so totally
your style of humor
i really enjoyed that scene i enjoyed
that scene so much when it came to it
because i was like oh this is just very
real one of my favorites comfortable
were you guys dating then was that weird
um yeah yeah season three yeah
we were we were definitely dating
um
is it a glimpse into your home like i'll
tell you what i'll tell you what was
weird i have no problems telling the
story because it's been so long ago when
we were in philadelphia shooting that
season
i remember um getting
we we spent so we none of us had kids
and all we would do is shoot all day and
then go out and get blind drunk remember
it was like a party we had so much fun
and we stayed in some hotel and so we
had just started dating like i mean not
that long
before that
um enough to where i was still like oh i
want to like impress this impress this
this young woman and we got i don't know
again blind drunk and the next morning
i wake up and she's like man you sweat
like
crazy last night is it hot in here i'm
like i usually sweat at night i don't i
don't know
and i'm like
yes sweaty and like the sheets are like
soaking wet and i'm like what the [ __ ]
like i i guess i am and then she was
like she smelled and she was like
you pissed all over me
i pissed the bed you pissed all over her
has
and has never happened since wow you
were that drunk i was that
inebriated that i peed on my new
girlfriend yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
i've definitely been like had to pee
really bad in the morning and had dreams
that i was going to pee and then that
that's what wakes me up and then i go
take a leak
but it never has somehow there's a
blocking mechanism and i don't know why
i don't pee in bed but i don't yeah i
don't know why i did in that
in particular
moment either live but i've been an
idiot before inebriated since did her
reaction to you peeing on the bed and
all over her
uh
make you go wow this woman is really
something else she thought it was the
funniest thing
that's what i mean and i was like we're
gonna get i'm marrying i'm jerry
dude yes that's what sealed the deal of
us deciding to get married and since
then we've lived in wedded bliss i
remember this is a funny memory but i
remember
shooting that thing where i find the
alibaba sword in the dump and i remember
you know them being like this is going
to be hard to shoot like this is bigger
production value this whole episode has
a lot more production value than ours
um you know rain machines and [ __ ] but
uh
even that they had to build that mound
of garbage and i was like why don't we
just like go to a dump somewhere
and they're like buddy you don't want to
just be in the dump rummaging around the
trash and
not until now watching it was i like oh
yeah i didn't want to just be yeah
so i think they i think we were actually
fighting for that we were like because
it was so expensive just
give it a little budget
exactly and then we were like let's just
go to a dump we can do it we can do it
we can do it and
fox was like you can not fx was like you
cannot too much of a liability
yeah
yeah
and the crew will be breathing in the
garbage air all day charlie do you
remember if um
chopping a camel in its hump with this
thing and drinking the milk off the tip
of the sword if that line was uh
scripted or just no
way
no way you you i remember distinctly you
making that up in the middle in the in
the middle of that scene you do yes
i was like that is insane it is so
[ __ ] funny what he's talking about
chopping a camel in its hump and
drinking its milk
i was like this dude who is this guy
like who comes up with something that
funny that fast it was probably a combo
for me
not knowing whether or not there was
actually milk in there
you know like like doing the rift but
also being like slightly unsure like is
it water is it milk is it just like
is it just a cellular growth what's in
there
what's in that camel stop i don't
actually know it's important to embrace
our ignorance and and go with it because
there is a lot of comedy in what we
actually don't know yeah yeah yeah
here's how i know that that was that was
definitely uh an ad-lib the line i
believe was and i bet i bet you if we
dig up the script we could find it the
line was frank it's an alibaba sword and
so you start with check out what i found
i can
cut a helmet and then he gives a line
and you keep going over over him to get
in the actual line which is it's an
alibaba sword which you must have felt
like was necessary for some reason yeah
and and it wasn't but you but you you
had ad-libbed all this funny things you
said danny was being a professional and
trying to throw in whatever whatever it
was that he was supposed to say and then
charlie like finish the finish the line
right i'd have to go back and watch that
again this this episode was the first
one that jerry levine uh directed
um and i remember being so like so like
nerdy excited because
i grew up watching the movie teen wolf
like i've seen that movie a thousand
times and jerry levine plays uh the
character styles and he's just so funny
in it he's so good did you guys grow up
watching that movie yes i mean it wasn't
one of those that i would watch over and
over again but i'd seen it i think i saw
it once and i was like it's uh it's not
for me the hair bothers me yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah the world is upsetting
yeah it is upsetting he's in short short
shorts i feel uncomfortable it's also
confusing because it was like
he was really hairy obviously because he
was a werewolf
um
and yet
somehow he that made him sexier
to people and to women and more popular
it's like if a dude shut up like that in
a real high school they'd be like
they'd kill him they'd
it's a monster yeah it's a monster we
know it's a monster we've seen movies
about this monster yeah numerous movies
yeah you know just because he wants to
play basketball doesn't mean he's not up
to something and why is it why is a
werewolf naturally better at basketball
than well i think that uh
wolf just has jumping abilities that a
human doesn't i think what it is is
michael dribble the michael j fox the
michael j from the human combo coming in
that's exactly the michael j fox guy he
was a decent basketball player but then
when you add like the physical abilities
of a werewolf into the mix then
you know you've got uh yeah you've got a
real situation on your hands yeah and
michael j fox like all men who are 5'2
are probably pretty good at basketball
but what does it take to really excel
and that's that's a werewolf jeans
well i believe that that movie
is about puberty isn't it
i think that's the whole thing it's like
it's i think it's supposed to be like
you know hair is coming so the fact that
you're talking about hair and then like
why women fight it's like i think it's
like you're transforming into uh right
dudes don't worry the hair is okay yeah
you can still be somebody despite all
this new hair that was the message
that's the message
yeah because with that hair comes like
mad hops then our buddy jason bateman
did teen wolf too
and that's t-o-o yeah as in team wolf
also yeah so listener please go check
that out check out teen wolf 2 with
jason bateman almost ruined his career
right that almost
that almost that put him in the movie
jail for a little bit i think it might
happen to him i feel like that's i
believe that i don't have words in his
mind
and he was a he was a boxer in that
movie right and they didn't get jerry
levine to play got like a different guy
to play styles no you know not to bag on
that guy i don't know who that guy is
but like you know jerry levine
jerry levine was like amazing in that
movie he's so funny i never understood
why he stopped acting and just became a
director he's a great director too but i
do miss that genre of
movie which is like
that 80s
comedy
that feels very
inexpensively produced yeah but like
just pure fun i just feel like that's
kind of gone away yeah it's gone
is it ah
i mean you know there's a handful of
them that come out these days i mean i
like book smart was you know like a high
school comedy because that was just
so so great
um but yeah it's not there's not as many
of them as there were in the 80s the 80s
were really really a heyday for those uh
high concept stupid silly comedies well
speaking of stupid silly comedies what
else about this dumpster baby uh do you
guys want to ask you guys um i wanted to
ask you guys like do you remember how
the idea how this idea came about and
like
where the idea of like finding a baby in
a dumpster and how it tied in with like
global warming and throwaway culture and
all that well certainly um uh
an inconvenient truth had just come out
i think the previous year and so that
was a huge part of the the popular
culture and conversation but then also
at the same time uh unrelated there was
like three or four different
stories about people finding
babies in the trash really yes
and and and we were like what the [ __ ]
is going on why are people throwing out
and your first shot
now that's funny
well well i think yeah yeah yeah right
we were like you know
yeah i mean i wasn't that always the
goal of the show to take things that
nobody else were taught was talking
about and see if we could find a comedic
spin to it which is like hey the act in
and of itself is not funny but man what
what would happen if characters like
this f found i guess we never really say
like who the parents were or anything
right it's just that the baby's in the
trash and then the baby goes to child
services yeah at the end and now that
baby's probably
14 15 years old right i think older than
that can we try to track that baby how's
db doing how's db i would like to i
would actually i'm sure it was a set of
twins right because they always have
twins yeah when you have a baby on set
they might have been triplets
it was triplets
it was triplets you're right yeah so
it's a weird hollywood thing where it's
like okay you get five minutes with each
baby and if this one's not performing
you know this one's a good crier you
know this one's good at your goo gagas
and uh this one nails the google gaga's
almost every time this one he cries a
lot what do you want
this one's got kind of a wonky eye so
you want to shoot over his shoulder
but like
you know this was the music this was the
mutant you don't want this one yeah for
the cute shots but yeah he's he's going
to have the best career yeah the guy
with the wonky eye is going to have the
best cards eventually
[Music]
i know that yeah really he's got to be
in the credits right
no i mean no no maybe they didn't want
it maybe they saw it in dumpster baby
he's not online
[Laughter]
he is dvd what do you mean he's not on
imdb
oh that was teed up beautifully oh well
oh god oh i'm waking up
yeah i was i i remember this whole
season
we definitely got to the editing room
and we were devastated every every time
and it wasn't because we had um terrible
editors in fact josh drisco's been with
us from day one i think we overwrote
these episodes i think we we would write
episodes that would be like 40 pages we
did we had to hack them down so much
yeah well our run time was longer right
so we were given a little bit more
length and i i like that actually
watching this episode i'm like oh
there's a little more room for a few
more twists and turns which i think is
good yeah
but we also you know we were
figuring it out as we went so we're like
i don't know how many pages equals the
22 minutes we're allotted so
you know we're guessing it's 30 or maybe
it's 28 and then sometimes we riff and
things get expanded and yeah some of
those episodes were but you get it you
get a cut that's 35 minutes long and you
got to cut it down to 22 minutes like
yeah you you end up cutting a bunch of
jokes uh that don't necessarily progress
the story just to make sure that the
story stays on track
you know because you can't cut like
crucial story beats without you know
compromising things usually i mean
sometimes you can but so you gotta so
you end up cutting jokes and it's very
painful
to cut jokes because boy do you think
you're funny you watch like i'm so funny
here you want to cut this i don't
remember anything that got cut from that
episode though no nor do i it doesn't
know you don't need it do you guys
remember how hard it was to get riders
on the storm that song was it hard i
don't remember it was expensive and we
had to sort of push for it yeah
it's so good in the episode like i love
that scene with you and danny in the in
the rain by the dumpster yeah yeah so do
i i
you know it's funny i don't really
remember shooting that
but i do remember him and i just
sleeping on the subway great which we
shot in philly
there's a couple scenes we shot in
philly my stepmother's in the show
oh yeah mary mary yeah
my mother's wife yeah yeah with lucy
yeah with lucy devito yeah yeah when
they're the the two ladies that stop you
and d when you're walking down the
street with db and they're like oh
they're such they gave us the idea for
to to put put them in commercials
there's a shotgun there i don't love
which is you guys looking right into the
crate yeah
that was pretty stylized from the baby's
point of view
that's like why are we in the baby's
point of view we're not in the baby's
point of view anywhere else in the
storytelling so then to jump into the
baby's point of view it felt weird to me
but
yeah you know whatever it's not i don't
know if that doesn't make a break we
should re-cut it i think it's not too
late to maybe reshoot yeah
let's get jerry levine on the phone and
see if he can explain to us what he was
thinking he'll definitely remember that
might have been us i feel like maybe
that was like one of the things that we
pitched to him like hey let's do this
he's like yeah whatever you guys want
it's your show
i think it hits i kind of want to
reshoot that i kind of want to reshoot
an episode
from like season one or season two shot
for shot that might be funny yeah that
might be fun and just seemingly
depressing oh it'll be oh it'll be
horrifically depressing it'll be
humiliating which is great would we
change the dot would we would it be the
same story but like the dialogue's
exactly the same because i feel like we
don't make this quite the same jokes it
might be interesting to do
a story where
we're we're doing the same things right
but we don't realize it but every now
and then one of us is like some of this
feels familiar to me
but
it's like basically the exact same story
yeah but and then maybe someone's like
no we've done this before there's like
no way we would just make the same
mistakes and the episode's about just
like sort of making the same mistakes
over and over but that's a good idea
guys this is something that the gang
recycles trash
did we do it one where we recycle our
trash again we might have done like a
sequel to that
i don't know we only did one no this
one's about trash
as well
uh the trash stuff i enjoyed so much
well
i remember being on set too and a lot of
that's
improv i remember you turning to frank
when you're just looking through the
trash and talking about how great it is
and saying holding up something and
saying electrics yeah electric
electrics yeah yeah danny's saying that
whatever that thing's like a ray gun
like the little yeah yeah yeah yeah
taking the hose he was talking about
with the hose he's like oh you can wrap
things up with this yeah you can we can
we'll just wrap stuff up
so excited about it
uh should we own up to um one of our
mistakes in this season
um when it comes to the production
design
oh
oh the floor i didn't even notice it in
the episode but yeah i wanted to say
this one but i remember this being the
the season where somebody did did that
happen without us realizing without us
knowing yes yes
so what had happened was that
the the floor of the bar in season one
and two was was flooring that was
existed in the space that we were
filming the herald exactly
yeah this parquet floor
uh
and it's very expensive to create and
produce that and so and in order to like
cut corners and save some money
they had decided not to replicate like
our some i don't want to throw anyone
specific under the bus but because we
were shooting in the examiner where it
just if that was that was the floor
right so
someone had said hey let's cut a corner
save some money and they change the
floor of the bar to just these like flat
brown wood planks they also really
brightened up the colors in sweet dee's
apartment with like bright purples and
stuff
and we didn't realize you know because
you're not doing a million things you
until we got into the editing room we're
like what is different why is this all
feeling different yeah
and eventually you know season four we
changed it back but we shot the whole
season with different [ __ ] floors it
drove us crazy but did did we ever hear
anybody like i've never heard anybody
mention it
check the reddit meg check the round is
there is there a sunny floor reddit
i don't know
i don't
it's more like us our own sense of like
quality you know
yeah that it's irritating yeah and that
was not the alleyway
now that was a different alleyway that
was a sort of fake set alleyway which
was right off of
this warehouse that we were filming in
oh right from a production standpoint i
get it it was like let's say money let's
let's try to get everything all in one
location so we're not spending a lot on
company moves moving the entire place
downtown just to shoot in a stinky
alleyway
but
i don't know
something feels lost yeah you know what
was great about that alley whenever we
shot down down there is that it was the
that door to paddy's
is a working restaurant oh yeah it was a
korean restaurant no no it was um uh
those little
like
meat-filled sandwich things like what
are they calling us
yeah it was an empanada place it was oh
yeah i'm positive well either way it was
it was a working restaurant and i
remember that we never ever were able
to ask them like to buy out the
restaurants so
the and they would the owner or whoever
the general manager wouldn't tell the
staff like to stop cooking or what was
happening so not stop
making empanadas i i implore you no
matter what happens today
keep your head down get those empanadas
made
all right don't stop
okay
they might be behaving weirdly don't
look at them don't acknowledge them just
make empanadas the love of god make
empanadas
god forbid a cop walks in here and we're
not making empanadas and they this whole
thing goes to [ __ ] you know because nate
nobody buying his empanadas it's all
front it's what's inside the empanadas
you know if you know what i'm like
well yeah so we would have access to it
and the door would open and we would go
in and generally it would be like like
us bursting out the door because we
didn't want to see in but there would be
times between like when when before we
would roll and then like you'd be inside
this restaurant where they're making
empanadas yeah preparing to do have your
do your exit yeah and there's like a guy
and you have a radio and they're like
okay action you're like did he say
action i don't know what did he say
actually because they're blasting music
yeah
and the guys like they wouldn't even
really even look at us
they couldn't care there's something
going on in there right maybe there was
they were filling those empanadas with
something that's a funny little thing
about this business where that happens a
lot like you go on a location scout or
something and you're like walking
through like a weird kitchen of a
working place and it's you and a team of
people and no one ever tells the people
working there they don't ever shut it
down like maybe
usually like a big movie will like buy
the place out for a while but most
places are like no keep the empanadas
going we'll be in and out we just need
your doorway
that's something that just happened this
year
we were shooting the scene where you and
i were walking down the street in dublin
and um we were doubling it with another
street and and they just didn't lock it
down at all so every time we would go
back to our starting point there would
be like some guy that would come up and
be like hey mac and charlie we'd be like
hey bud he's like hey can i take a photo
we're like sure there's but we're in the
middle of a scene like yeah all good
like no problem but is there any
lockdowns is there any security is there
this is something you've been bitching
about for years you're always like don't
you're always like you we we talked to
the locations people were like can we
lock this street down we need to lock
the street down they're like
you just can't
la county will not let you lock down a
city street and i'm like
you i've seen jerry bruckheimer movies
where they're blowing cars up and people
up and helicopters up in the middle of
the street are you telling me you didn't
lock that down yeah there's just there's
just like some guy driving by in his
honda civic right is that transformers
blowing up and then the answer is well
oh well no yeah you can do it
yeah and the right price you just said
you we can't do it well you can't do it
no sorry what i meant is you can't do it
is your last name brookheimer yeah yeah
no but it's equally difficult to
pronounce
[Music]
what park was that where we had chained
uh what's that actor's name to the tree
he was very funny he was great and he
was great in it yeah i don't remember
what park that was uh i think it was a
park on la siena yeah um but when you're
cutting over towards the airport yes
yeah yes we shot there a couple times we
have shot there danny being stuck in the
coil yeah yeah todd grinnell tucker
he was great and our friend isaac played
mountain oh he's great yeah isn't he
great yeah he's so great in it he's
there's another guy who was i was always
like i think he why is he not an actor
he's a surprise prop mastery
it's just you're better
it's that it's that weird thing about
like the person just is the person
and it's interesting to watch jackie
tone yeah jackie tone
was she on american idol
she's gone on to do some other well
as well but she's a singer she was a
singer right yeah she's a singer and a
musician i feel like she was on like
america's got talent or she was american
idol maybe i think she was on american
idol uh danny hill
mary elizabeth's friend who plays the
guy in the tanning bed oh the original
yeah yeah yeah i hear that i hear that
often just to get a base people just
together
i always found that very very funny i
don't we don't need a full tan yeah we
just need to lay the base layer down do
you guys you don't tan right you don't
don't do me yeah do i look like i tan no
i know you don't know
you might go
you don't go out of your way to tan
right now no no no that's this
skin is not yeah yeah made to tan not
made to tap pretty crazy thing to go
into a tanning booth and just like
cook me
cook yourselves yeah yeah because for me
i was always tempted to do it when i was
single because i was always like i'm so
pale like like just get a little bass
and keep it yeah sure you know what i
mean like i don't need to be like you
know
orange orange or even fully brown i just
need to be like a lit i just need to
look like i've spent a little bit of
time in the sun
you know why not just pop that shirt off
when you go play a little basketball wow
well now i'll do i will do that i do do
that glenn's but glenn's
rightfully so but you started earlier
than most of us when we would go to the
beach together when we lived in venice
or marina del rey and
i would show up and uh and you would you
would look purple i know you had so much
sunblock on yeah it was a very weird
shade of purple yeah that the because it
would be like a very specific kind of
sound it's that mineral sunscreen yeah
right that goes on and it just looks
like a like a thing of white and it and
it for me and my skin it turns me purple
yeah i i don't use that wow this this is
hardcore it has not but it was great
[Music]
i've had enough things locked off my
skin from from sun damage i mean when i
was a kid when i was a kid we would go
to the beach and and there was no sun
block my mother used to spray us with
vinegar yeah to get to to get you dark
yeah well it was to keep the flowers
the funniest thing picturing these like
what mcelhenny kids just reeking of
vinegar imagining like you coming over
to a kid like hey you guys want to play
uh frisbee or something like oh god
my eyes are watering trying to talk to
the skin [ __ ] man how much fish and
chips did you have what the [ __ ] are you
this guy smells like a [ __ ] salad
crazy crazy even worse than that the
second you go in the water that vinegar
is off yeah but when you came out she
had more of it she just wow
she's got the vinegar
now i asked her like why why was i
sprayed down with vinegar it's and i'm
like do you think that they'd help to
like engage the sun in some way and she
was like uh it's um by the way it's it's
still unclear 100 percent she's like
honey i was loaded up yeah yeah she was
100
no doubt we would go down there with her
and her sisters and her
because friends jersey they had these
like horse flies that would bite you oh
yeah yeah
it was like
they don't like the vinegar so it keeps
the flies away from you and then but no
no
no my kids covered in vinegar and flies
yeah yeah they're street like vinegar
they always get flocks around
and
she also loved for some reason
she loved the look of those like of like
those like swimmer like like in the
european oh no like they look like
underwear right those aren't okay yes
yes like a swimmer like a swimmer she
loved that look right and we were too
young but i was old enough i was
probably like nine ah
nine or it wasn't nine or ten and she
was like you just look so cute in these
and meanwhile like you know maybe at
like
six you don't care but by the time you
hit like 10 you're like my dick is tiny
and it looks so bad yeah like so much
smaller yeah like i yeah and so now i'm
aware
god only knows how it's reacting to the
vinegar too yeah right shriveled
up yeah yeah yeah like a
balsamic
caring once like 10 or 11.
i remember there being like a group of
kids and me always like having my hands
over my dick and then like my cousin
being like look man there's no hiding
there's no hiding you got to get a new
suit you guys just got to get a new suit
and i was like all right i'd say so 11
years old you were still wearing like
the european uh maybe 10 yeah like i'll
get some i'll get some photos because we
have some photos i look happy in the
photos i do really enjoy when i see uh
it's always like an older gentleman it's
always a man like you know well into his
60s or above
you know and those guys are just like i
don't give a [ __ ] this is what i like
yeah this is what i want to wear this is
what i like this is what makes me
comfortable and i don't care how it
makes you feel
well i'll tell you what i was tan as
[ __ ] like for as as as irish skin that i
have i was like because we would be out
there on the beach every day covered in
vinegar with no clothing with no
clothing on so i was so tan the photos
you see of me i'm like this is crazy i
look so
so dark how does the vinegar affect the
sun does it does it make you get more
sun or does it actually block this i
think she from her point of view i think
it did have no no it didn't block the
sun i think it was like an or it would
have the same properties as like a baby
oil well i'm saying so it enhanced the i
believe so yeah like she wanted us tan
yeah right
just because that was the healthy look
you know right right i want my baby i
want my kids to look healthy yeah yeah
spray him and vinegar get him out yeah i
want this kid and if he's covered in
horse fly bumps then that negates the
whole thing sure yeah i'll do i need to
resemble a french fry
you know what i mean i look pretty good
if i'm being honest i mean i look like
you know like my dick didn't look great
when i was i was a little kid i don't
know if you should be looking a little
kid's dick anyway but like i think my my
body looked all right
[Laughter]
yeah i guess so
um what percentage of people are going
to try the vinegar thing now they're
like oh you really damn i'm trying to
vinegar listen i grew up in alabama
where we had a shitload of horse flies
and nobody ever sprayed me in vinegar
nobody ever suggested spraying you know
me down it could have been to [ __ ] with
us i don't know it could have been to be
like look we got to toughen this kid up
right so we got to get him out there and
like having kids pick at him so he can
i don't know get the so he can spend the
rest of his life over compensating yes
it's a bizarre move one way or the other
yeah yes just to spray yourself in
vinegar is very strange yeah i should
have always had my mom on the podcast
and
have her answer i feel like i don't
remember anything oh i don't know you're
supposed to get vinegar all over you on
it that's what you do
[Laughter]
stop robbie you loved it when when uh
when was your mom uh when did your mom
and mary get together how old were you
oh i i
very young
nine ten something like that no okay
yeah for they've been together for all
right so she was involved depends on who
you are these were these these were
nurses by the way yes yes
mary was not a nurse uh but my mother
was my mother was so i thought actually
at this point my mother was not a nurse
she was in nursing school
she was uh she had just transitioned
from um pyramid scheme
salesman into she was like we have this
thing called shaklee
which is basically neutral neutral life
or or amway like it's in that so it's
like excitement supplements and vitamins
and whatever and and i just remember
they were there was like shackly pills
everywhere i mean she was she's a
go-getter like she was like uh
entrepreneur yeah and he's like i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna get up i'm
gonna become a part of this thing and
i'm gonna sell i'm gonna be the best
shackley salesman
philadelphia yeah and then i just i
don't think anybody bought them in south
philly there right now that's the thing
about the pyramid scheme it's about
selling to the person who's going to
sell yeah yeah you're constantly trying
to offload it not to the customer but to
the person who's going to be under your
salesman yeah yeah we addressed that on
the show as well oh yeah we hit it god
we've done everything haven't we
we haven't done vinegar i mean maybe we
can do a thing about vinegar i don't
know
megan can you jot that down just so we
don't forget for season 16 we want to do
a vinegar episode you guys should look
into vinegar as a sponsor
what are the popular vinegars that are
oh there's uh i tell you i'm a big fan
of a salt and vinegar chip i'm like oh
come on buddy i will go nuts on a salt
and vinegar bag of chips yeah i bet you
my skin tasted like salt and vinegar
chips right because it's salty it's
salty it's vinegar sun it's baking it's
baking into the
so maybe maybe you smelled great maybe
you smelled like a bag of salt and
vinegar potato chips they don't smell
good though no they don't they don't no
it's on vinegar chips don't smell good
not to me i i don't like this i like it
yeah why do you i mean not it doesn't
stop me from from eating them yeah so
maybe we would have been friends when
when when we were kids
like i accept you would you would you
have accepted vinegar kid i doubt i
might have been thrown off by the speedo
yeah more than the vinegar
well then once i got close then the
vinegar would have just yeah overpowered
right you you see the speedo and you're
like i'm going to give this kid a shot
i'm going to give him a shot do you get
closer he also smells like vinegar it's
like that's
that's too many things this is too much
that's too many things
smell like vinegar i don't remember any
speedos in new england i don't ever
remember i don't recall any speedos in
jersey so it was just yes it was just
the mackerel honeys do mac like boys
just pat me and patrick and i yeah that
was it you know what i'm not a fan of is
the thong like uh on the beach like like
the thong is very popular
and i i don't know it's i don't like the
look you like a little mystery yeah it
makes it look like a rhino's butt to me
you know what i mean like it's like like
like it makes the crack look longer than
it should be is there also something to
like you know how that thing where it
looks uncomfortable too if somebody is
scantily clad it's more attractive than
someone who's just like completely naked
do you see do you do you feel that way
wait say that again meaning like
when there's a little air of mystery
where you're like i can see
aspects of your nudity and your body
through your clothing for example
is maybe more attractive than someone
who's just like nude yes i i agree with
that yeah i like a little mystery yeah
meg like when you see a juicy dong
hanging down somebody's pant leg is that
better than seeing the dong itself yeah
which how do you
an adult thong or a 10 year old no no
we're talking about yeah yeah yeah how
do you like your dongs i like
i don't want to see any more than half
of it right yeah sure but you don't mind
seeing the top
yeah a little bush
yeah that makes sense that's how i feel
about the tongue man it's like
like elephant man do you like to see
like uh like an outline like would you
find the outline of a dick in a pants
attractive or just weird
um i don't find it it's like it's
specifically a tool for something so
it's like to me it's like a plunger i
don't care what it looks like
as long as it works like the visual
element is not what it is yeah that's
right yeah that's so i've never thought
of it that way but you're totally right
women are generally not as visual it's
the means to an end
right it's a means to an end yeah like
if i was if the guy was like i know how
to use a plunger i'd be like cool but if
he was like look how cool my plunger
looks i'd be like i don't give a [ __ ]
can you use can i unclog my toilet yeah
i don't care how it looks yeah you're on
the a train it's 4 30 in the morning guy
opens his trench coat there's this
plunger right you're like buddy there's
not even a toilet on this thing why am i
looking at your plunger yeah yeah yeah
what is this man
what a train is this what kind of train
is this
[ __ ] smelly vinegar man yeah i'm
gonna take up some photos of you as a
kid yeah oh i'd like to see that oh yeah
because i'm i'm fa i just remembered
that do we have a website yet megan we
have uh social media
let's try let's try to get yeah see if
you can get your hands on some of those
photos and let's get those up on the
internet let's make sure the world sees
them great
uh because i want i i want to see them
and i want the world to see them if
you're okay with that yeah i think and
maybe maybe
uh and and this is for you guys out
there when these photos hopefully do pop
up on uh our social media go ahead and
take that photo
and put some
you know some lot some stinky lines
coming off him you know what i mean so
that he's so that he's like what was the
kid from the pink from peanuts
yeah but it's like but it's like vinegar
just sort of like you know baking off of
your off of your body so if you don't
put any flies on him the flies will be
around him but they won't land on him no
yeah they won't yeah if it flies they'll
come in and be like not that guy like
let's go get the other guy yeah just
like the girls yeah they'd be like
yeah same but vinegar has the same
effect yeah she was repelling flies and
friends yeah every time you went to the
beach and we weren't into it i wasn't
like yeah get me i was like i don't get
it i hate vinegar i just mom can we just
not she's like look you just gotta do it
i'm like okay
did you ever did you ever get your way
and and mom was like all right fine
we're not we won't do the vinegar
and let's see how you did with the with
the horse flies
yeah
well then yeah i don't know when the
transition
was did you ever get by oh [ __ ] yeah it
[ __ ] hurts
they call them green heads yeah in
jersey but they were the same the same
idea right there weren't any horses
around they were mean they were [ __ ]
mean like you would be swimming in a
swimming pool like at our house or my
friend's house or whatever
and there'd be like
there's always like one horse fly who
was just like
just wanted us you know what i mean just
want to get out why are you are they
eating whatever they bite
is it what
[Music]
yeah what do they what do they want from
us female horse flies require blood
during summer's mating season which is
why they bite people okay okay so they
want but they'll take the blood
like women
like women
during mating season they will they need
they need your blood they need your
blood they want your blood so that's
what they're that's what they're after
they want to get under the skin get that
blood and and then uh just the females
yeah okay and they and they they do this
they'll do this to any animal right not
just not just humans obviously they're
called horse flies so they do it to
horses but they'll take any kind of
blood that they can get god what in
existence just flying around me like i
need blood
yeah you know yeah just looking for
[ __ ] blood just [ __ ] flying around
needing blood
can you imagine you see it okay you are
mad you see like a group of kids like
playing in a pool and you're just like i
can't ah look at all that blood oh [ __ ]
they're covered in vinegar
i can't get to their blood
for uh the years of abuse that's what
i'm talking about for with the from the
kids yeah you were the vinegar kid and
you'll never let it you'll never be able
to let that always be the kid with the
little dick that the smell like vinegar
yeah yeah in my mind
so i have to keep achieving achieving i
don't know and what is that something
prove yeah
doesn't everybody have that like a
little bit yeah something to prove i
think anyone who's an actor in hollywood
has a little bit of that like for sure
something to prove yeah kind of thing
yeah yeah i'd say my chip is yeah
directly proportionate to the size of
the chip is directly and proportionate
to the uh
opposite size of
my deck yeah right
yeah the smaller
the smaller the penis the bigger the
chip is what you're saying yeah i think
maybe yeah maybe yeah it's a salt and
vinegar chip
that's something
that should be the end right there
[Music]
great can you guys do me one favor and
clap yep
i can't clap
[Music]